Les diré exactamente cómo hacerlo.
Atrapé algunos mosquitos afuera.
A diferencia de Bill Gates, no los voy a soltar.
(Risas)
Pero les diré cómo hacer esto.
Todo lo que se hace es tocarlos y vuelan.
Lo pueden probar primero.
Realmente puedo oír eso.
Y con su teléfono que tiene micrófono,
los micrófonos ya funcionan tan bien,
incluso en los teléfonos regulares,
que se puede recoger esta firma de campo cercano.
Y como no tengo tiempo,
les pongo la grabación que hice hace un día.
(Zumbido de mosquitos)
Esto es todo el sonido encantador que oyeron antes
que a todos Uds. les encanta.
Uno de los contextos de este
es poder hacer esto con un teléfono móvil común
lo que nos permite mapear especies de mosquitos.
Usando un teléfono móvil,
mapeamos una de las bases de datos acústicas más grandes
con 25 a 20 especies de mosquitos que portan patógenos humanos.
Y de este aprendizaje y de la máquina,
cualquiera que cargue estos datos,
se pueden identificar y decir la probabilidad
de qué especies de mosquitos están trabajando.
Llamamos a esto Abuzz, y si alguno de Uds. desea inscribirse,
solo tiene que ir al sitio web.
Permítanme cerrar con algo
muy importante y querido para mi corazón.
Uno de los desafíos de hoy es que tenemos problemas terribles.
Mil millones de personas sin ningún cuidado de salud,
cambio climático, pérdida de biodiversidad, etc.
Y esperamos que la ciencia dé la respuesta.
Pero antes de salir de esta sala hoy,
quiero que prometan una cosa.
Vamos a hacer accesible la ciencia,
no solo para las personas que pueden permitírselo,
sino a otros mil millones que no pueden.
Hagamos de la ciencia y la alfabetización científica un derecho humano.
Al pasarle a los niños la sensación de hormigueo
de hacer un descubrimiento
uno les permite que sean el siguiente grupo de personas
que resolverá estos problemas.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)